overdrive that's a video game that's
coming out this year there's not many NM
impacts that we're joined by mr. Brown
and Winfrey head of community hello how
are you damn sure and insomniac yes
first of all show everyone your boots
okay those are great boots I know your
shirt says sex burger that's pretty good
too but the boots are the best thank you
very much i'm jen so yeah I'm from
Memphis Tennessee so I always gotta
represent I'm allowed to wear these
women when people wear these and then up
in the south yeah hmm I'm a little
judgey I wait were you at Gamescom I was
did you see there's a store that only
sold snake boots they only swear to God
in Germany they love americans yeah yeah
it's wild I think that yeah it's like
that baywatch david house yeah I'm
staying there that's yeah that's a
really yeah I love the hot so if you are
in connects time you're in Cologne go
like west of the messe and there's just
bad snake boots during the way I will
purchase some great we're not here to
talk about sneaky look good they're
probably like the boss name i'm sorry i
don't know what they're these these are
purchased yeah we're still talking about
that sorry I need to talk about sunset
or what I do it hey you guys you're
playable in the xbox booth yes are
people getting hands on it at this is
kind of like insomniacs I don't know
it's like you guys did like resistance
and Raj it and it's kind of like this
yeah yeah worlds collide they made sweet
love together yeah and that pops this
baby of this country baby that drinks
energy drinks yeah the sunset overdrive
is really kind of a game that we've been
almost building up to for 20 years we've
been a studio yeah it just combines kind
of our love of platforming elements and
crazy weapons and just combine them all
into this fast-paced colorful humorous
game so yeah we've we've loved working
on and it's awesome to just work on a
game that we really wanted to work on
yea though we got a bunch of gameplay
footage other I think it's alright the
kind of you need to see actually you
know what actually need to play it but
yeah get it yeah and yeah what's up in
like cuz it's it's one of these games
that I think people are sort of reacting
to like they're not really sure if they
want to play it right and when people
get their hands on it they're kind of
like oh ok I kind of get what it is yeah
sure that's kind of a challenge for you
guys yeah see those it's a different
type of game it's
it's not a normal third person shooter
we're just sitting there shooting away
like that's we want to be the anti bat
like we want you to constantly be moving
and traversing at the same time while
shooting and I think that's just
whenever you bring something new to the
table I think some people are just going
to be a little reverse to that but once
they once they get it and there is a
there's a learning curve like will be
fully we're fully aware that it takes
some time to get used to shooting and
moving at the same time but but you get
there really quickly and all of a sudden
you're just you're going eight see this
guy is staying on the ground right now
and he's taking damage because that the
ground is dangerous that's kind of
something we talk about a lot is the
floor is lava so you'll you'll die if
you stay in the ground but that's ok cuz
we we we were video game that's another
thing we're very aware of I've seen your
respawn animations pretty varied and
ridiculous because it's one of the
situations where fun Trump's realism for
us yeah like I feel like a lot of games
nowadays are trying to pretend that
they're not video games and for us it
was the complete opposite it's like
we're making a video game let's go wild
and have fun so from all the games that
you've been showing you very much for
focusing on the moment to moment
actually what's going on like right what
is it what is that what are you trying
to do in terms of like the moments
moment gameplay is it chaining is it
yeah up your doctor what's the kind of
like the focus right so it's I would say
it's its momentum based gameplay so
essentially what you're doing is you
want to constantly be moving and
traversing at the same time while
shooting and you see here up in this
right hand corner you see a style meter
and that is that's kind of something you
always want to be focused on because as
you're getting style your unlocking your
amps and your unlocking special
abilities like right here is susan's
using this melee attack here where it
summons tornadoes that's an amp so the
only we're gonna have that amp is if
you're playing stylish Lee and you have
your style meter up so it's very
momentum base where you always want to
keep your kill combos up and switch up
your weapons and traversal always get
that style meter up and that's when
you're gonna be playing at your most
badass so are you unlocking abilities
are you focusing in one direction like
hammer well in terms of customization
right right so it's going on there
there's full visual customization like
there's that but as far as like ability
customization we have stuff called amps
and amps are equippable on your
character you can have four or five on
your character at all times and they
slide into different section like
there's a melee one there's kind of a
traversal one there so there's a weapon
one and that's what ever you want to do
there's there's Epic Games prob like a
chance of thunder where lightning just
strikes down and there it's destroying
everything in the area and that's at a
high level of play but you can really so
not only can you customize your
character visually but you can customize
how you want to play like if you want to
focus on fire damage you can do that
through the amp system at sunset City
that's where that's right yeah beautiful
sunset City myself nice yeah that's how
big is it it's pretty how important is
that in terms of a game like this like
pretty huge so the city itself is is
really big from distance the distance in
like it's it's it's really buried but I
think also something that's super unique
about our game is we had to cuz it
focuses so much on traversal yeah
there's so much of it that's built
vertically I'm trying to see if you'll
get a good shot from this footage but I
don't know if you will but like the we
we built so much of it just focus on the
vertical design not just the horizontal
design and that was super important to
us because honestly as you're going
through the city as you you'll start off
kind of where the buildings aren't super
high so it's a little bit easier to get
around but as you're moving through the
city you go to the towards the ending
areas they're gonna be skyscrapers so
you're gonna have to know your traversal
system really well in order to get
around super well so are you thread the
campaign I you
unlocking areas are you like clearing
out the entire or like what's your main
motivation yeah kind of the drive is you
kind of want to you kind of want to
escape sunset sitting along the way your
meeting these new factions which are
people who are also surviving the
apocalypse like you so you're meeting
these factions this isn't a fashion guy
but I just love them because he's the
king scab but are you going through and
there's different ones like let's see we
have the far guards and the troop
Bushido and your H have their different
problems and different ways that you can
help them out so in there and it kind of
in their own area so it's kind of slow
up into that where you're helping these
guys and you know eventually maybe you
all band together who knows so cool so
it's a primarily single player co-op
self out there is there's an entire
co-op mode as well it's a player co-op
it's called chaos squad and you can play
with seven of your friends and I'm
saying that that's when the game gets
wild and it's called chaos squad for a
reason but it's not outside of the main
single-player stuff right yeah a single
player it's just a story-driven
experience where you're doing your thing
but everything you unlock in single
player you can take back over to
multiplayer and vice versa so you look
exactly like your character when you go
to multiplayer but the multiplayer is
it's really simple to go until you just
go up to a phone booth drop in and you
basically do missions in the open world
with your friends and then it all
culminates in this night defense which
is actually what we're showing at PAX
here this weekend so yeah so what's the
reception bin at the booth you guys are
in with the Microsoft so obviously the
Xbox exclusive right yeah What's Wrong
a.m. and yeah what's it like having
people play because you guys are kind of
like a studio been around like you've
got people back as far as 98 when they
played spiral yeah whereas on me I am
yeah is this a game you think you're
sort of cuz you're you know as your role
as community as a community manager and
is this a game do you think your
community is sort of adopting easily or
yeah I think it's I think people
recognize that this is insomniac is kind
of a group of misfits and I think they
recognize that this is this is a game
where you can just be who you want to be
and not only and just like it's a
reverence but also just in its style and
own so I think people are really
receptive to that and that's what people
love insomniac in the first place is
because they grew up on spyro and they
grew up on ratchet and they loved
resistance and seeing i think people
really recognize that this is this is an
evolution of who we are yeah more than
anything else as well and i think this
is sort of a problem that we have in the
sort of wider streaming games on the
internet it actually like looks like one
of the sort of first really good looking
next up is anyone but like in terms of
like the frame rate and everything else
as well right like how much of a focus
was there for you guys cuz you've always
made kind of like visually you know
caustic games right striking games right
was there ever worried that when you
make a game that's this sort of I don't
know colorful and vibrant men people who
were into like shooter games are gonna
go what the hell is this kiddy nonsan
right I mean you're always gonna face
that right that's always it's something
that people want but for us it was like
people have had that all last generation
you got to see that so let's provide
them with something near you guys made
one of whatever yeah we made a
resistance which was you know it had
that apocalyptic tone and this is the
opposite this is resistance with
confetti yeah like that's what this is
um so that's what mattresses and yeah
you always you may be worried about that
but for us it was like well we just want
to make something colorful and bright
and vibrant and for us the effects were
also a huge part of it as well so we put
a lot of focus into all these so when
you see when you shoot gun sometimes
you'll see blam come out like Barry spot
scott pilgrim ass yeah so which is great
because it was a video game inspired or
a comic inspired by a video game and
then inspired a movie and then we were
inspired by that movie so this full
circle I heard so was it that I hear Ted
Pryce talking about the young ones at
one stage reference yes yeah yeah yeah
there's lots deep into British tell ya
yeah there's our creative directors
humor and Marcus Smith they are just
they had a vision from the very
beginning about what they wanted this
game to be and they really know that
like it's it's it's kind of crazy
because normally when you're developing
a new IP it changes a time yeah like diz
you're naturally but this one the the
tone and everything has been
pretty consistent throughout the whole
thing and that's that's been exciting
and I think it really shows when the
other focus of it is in the full game
yeah so now guys are pretty close to
release those yeah tober it's going
October 28 yeah in North America and
then October thirty-first in Europe area
yeah so yeah and then there's a white
xbox bundled with it as well yes of
course yeah so it's basically it's the
green oh yeah the white one but if you
buy that when you get the game for free
essentially because it still 400 bucks
so yeah do that if you don't have an
xbox it reminds me of the kind of I
guess maybe around the xbox 360 like
first two years when dead rising came in
right and I was a game that yeah a lot
of people weren't necessarily sure NASA
glad I she's like jumping studio making
a spray western kind of game and there
are some parallels in terms of like at
least a vision that this is quite a sort
of the difference for sure for sure how
does it it must be strange making a game
you know I'm sure Microsoft to helping
you guys out in terms of like feedback
on this microphone I on terms I that's
my EMP body giving off the effects I
don't know okay say like I don't affect
that that's my I have an amp equipped on
myself that's good so a que si interview
gets pretty hard you can it's just
everything explodes like a you know
Microsoft are obviously like a partner
of you guys in terms of marketing and
right you know there's been so much
visibility of sunset overdrive life even
here online you guys have been it there
must be a pressure and being like you
know first party game right sorry a
third party game but like a game that
Sony coming airs on one console yeah
that perhaps you know doesn't have that
massive install base yeah does that
change how you guys like approach
development or like the game you make or
something I don't think so for us its
first from the very beginning is about
making the game we wanted to make and in
some next an independent studio and
Microsoft's been a great partner but for
us we wanted to own this IP like me and
that was super important in Microsoft
they were like yeah well we'll publish
it and you guys can own the IP and press
that was super important because do so
neo and resistance then yeah they only
reduces match it so this is we only
wanna put from here on out we just want
to own our own eye peas like it was it's
awesome and I think that that's been
really good for us as like an
independent studio to kind of have that
backing behind it is fantastic excellent
so what can people play out of your
booth so relax yes they can come play
chaos squad at the booth it's the eighth
player co-op experience come play it if
you win you get a fizzy pin cool is
pretty rad yeah yeah we've also got
bunches of this stuff I'm overcharged me
a drunk since you got here yeah like
that I actually I've never had one of
these I'm pure she drink right 90 pure
blood drinking right now man did you put
me on the spot what you put your mouth
your brand this boy all right here we go
mmm hope I don't turn it to me one go
skull it in one there you go you gotta
do it do for the community my chug chug
chug chug chug John's go Chuck Chuck
Chuck Chuck oh my mrs. suck so bad you
all right you like half way you can do
it but come on think about those snake
boots
my god oh hey go whoo you just destroyed
my body I oh you know that oh you're
gonna have a skip in your stone my god
yeah he's so sweet question throw it you
earned it BAM sorry production I was
doing he told me yeah yeah this is your
second PAX Prime yeah it is yeah what do
you think about the show and either you
know your job is right community right I
actually been I love it obviously like
it's you know you have III and you're
bigger like in your comic cons as well
but this is this is where the heart of
the community is yeah once I see people
go around and people come up to you and
just people that you have changed you
know their their lives from these games
and my life has been changed by games as
well so I relate a lot to that and just
hearing them say that it's always
amazing just to hear those stories
that's what keeps you going right like
that's why you make games is to make
people happy and to make them feel so
yeah got so many panels or meet and
greets or in uh we don't I think that I
hmm the Rev you meet and greet there's
the bus that's going around I saw yeah
it's got a big old friggin zombie dude
still having fun and not zombies right
what he intends mutants okay yeah
musings a trifecta of video game that
stuff exactly I'm yeah describe you seen
any cosplay event in Psalm next I have
there's been some that some guy came
today and he made his own high fidelity
weapon laurissa which is a crazy record
that shoots vinyl records yeah and he
made it and that was awesome already
yeah before the games even air yeah
which is Fanta I with the reason I love
sunset overdrive cosplay and the reason
I wear a lot is uh you just go to the
thrift store just like I'll take this
system this so just get any sort of late
80s Early 90s yeah anything I Ritz I
well Sunday I dress up when I work
because I like to i bought a beat
costume okay and I'm just gonna be a be
because why not you just you can so yeah
why not fun your man who wears snake
boots on ironically yeah all the time so
why not way dude exactly i can own it
it's that's what that's and that's what
the game is about just owning who you
are sorry yeah
I am as insomniac badger have you ever
seen anyone in a spiral cosplay I'm a
big spiral fine um I don't think I've
ever seen spiral cause I saw so it a
girl on force like spiral whoa no I
haven't seen that I will say I am I
dressed up for for Halloween we dress up
yeah and i bought a skylanders spyro's
okay and I'd war that and it was a child
so it was incredibly small but I won the
halloween counter this so and ice worth
it me it was worth it it was worth all
the uncomfortableness in the crotch area
I was a nice warden yeah you were in
town for the next couple days r anything
else you're gonna check out yeah well I
I am yeah I'd love checking out I love
of all yeah the indie mega booth is
something I yeah it's right as well
there's more on the sixth floor as well
oh yeah a whole other section then my
good friend he's making clothes castles
and I love that game so much so that's
in the indie mega booth is where I love
to spend my time at these kind of things
cuz that's something you don't get at
the bigger shows usually so and they're
just doing great things in that space
yeah it's pretty great II don't
necessarily get that stuff at e3 at all
am sweet huh Brandon from Asami ugh an
absolute pleasure thank you very much
very much excited Xbox one yeah
Wednesday over there October 28 / 28
you